on the a20 police that had to close the
road in both directions allowing
emergency access to the rows of cars
stuck travelling in the direction of
Dover bumper-to-bumper not moving for
hours on end not at all how these family
is expected to spend what should have
been the first night a blessed summer
holiday join the queue at half 9:00 this
morning and I don't I hear they're
searching every car which is just
ridiculous I mean and every bag
sometimes these images given exclusively
to Sky News show inside the port complex
this is the buffer zone where vehicles
have had to wait for almost two hours
as French border officials check every
single passport on the other side of the
border it's nearly empty frustrating for
the port and for ferry companies as
crossings are missed and have to be
rebooked the port of dover says it
raised concerns over french staffing
levels days ago overnight the Home
Office has confirmed it's sending extra
UK border staff to assist the French
authorities this is just a few miles out
of Dover this is where the queue starts
to move and there is just a little bit
of hope but in this direction we have
been speaking to so many families who
have been stuck here for many many hours
and will probably be here until the
morning from above the view of
yesterday's tailbacks gives us a sense
of the scale of the problem and a
boiling hot day for many it was
unbearable aid worker Ravi Singh saw
those images on social media he drove
for hours to deliver thousands of water
bottles ready to be handed out this
morning we work around the world in
refugee camp where there's no water and
this is Britain and I think the
government's are really prepared for
this special day like this and the
reason what they to provide some sort of
reassurance if this happens this is plan
B
on one of the busiest travel days of the
summer many drivers are asking how this
situation could have been allowed to
happen and there are now warnings the
disruption could last right through the
weekend and into Monday morning Harriet
Hadfield Sky News Dover